ان لهم المشاكل والعقبات
اعلن الملياردير الامريكيه لهم ماسك عن
ايتاحه خاصيه القياده الذاتيه للجميع
بنيان بذلك المرحله التجريبيه فاذا نظام
اصبح متاحه للاهلي اي شخص قام بدفع ثمنه
لتصبح هذه الميزات ترقيه مدفوعه بسعر 15$
فقط استعجال ماسك واختيار هذا التوقيت
لطرحي الميزه الجديده على نطاق الواسع
اعتبرها المحللون امرا خاطئا نظرا لكول
مركبات تسلا تخضع حاليا لتدقيق مكثف من
قبل المناظمين حيث قامت الاداره الوطنيه
للسلامه المرور على الطرق السريعه مؤخرا
لتوسيع تحقيقاتها في سلسله من الحوادث كما
انه في تحقيق وفصل يبحث في اكثر من 30
حادثه تتعلق بالسائق الالي
على كل حال المزيد مع لميس
وعاد اتصل باطلاقه ميزات القياده الذاتيه
الكامله في عام 2018 لكنها ظهرت اخيرا فقط
في تموز 2021 لعدد صغير بنفس سائقين
الخبراء والحذرين النظام الجديد المقدم من
تسلا هو امتداد لمزه السائق الالي لمساعده
مستخدمي سيارات تسلاح حيث تتوسع بوظائف
اليه مثل التوجيه الالي في المدن ووقوف
السيارات الاوتوماتيكي واستدعاء المركبات
الذكيه والتعرف على اشارات المرور وعلامات
التوقف
التكنولوجيا الحاليه تتطلب من السائقين
بقاء يدهم على عجله القياده للسيطره على
السياره في اي لحظه فكل 45 ثانيه يخبرك
البرنامج ان تشد عشره القياده لتتاكد من
انك منتبه وفي حال شعر السياره انك غير
منتبه فانها توقف القياده الذاتيه واذا
اوقفت القياده ذاتيه خمس مرات فانها تطردك
من البرنامج سيارات القياده ذاتيه الكامله
لتسلا هي بلا شكوى واحده من اكثر انظمه
القاده شبه المستقله تقدما في العالم
لكنها لا تزعل بحاجه الى الكثير من العمل
بحسب الخبراء
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وفي فقره الجانب الاقتصادي تنورنا دايما
الصحفيه والعلاميه في قسم الاقتصاد سمر
الماشطه سمر اهلا بك يعني متى ستصبح
سيارات ذاتيه القياده حقيقه وقياس سمر
يعني اسمعنا خلال سنوات الاخيره وعودرا
لنا كثيره بهذا الشكل صحيح سهام بدايه
هناك تجارب فاشله وهناك تجارب ناجحه للاسف
اول شيء اهم شيء نعرف انه السياره ذاتيه
القياده فيها خمس مستويات من صفر او يعني
السعر اللي هي غير ذاتيه القياده الى خمسه
ليا ذاتيه القياده بالكامل نحن اقرب ما
نكون اليوم بين اثنين وثلاثه اللي هي
الاسستنت او الاوتوبايلات المساعد اللي هي
ممكن انه همم تكبس المكابح ممكن تكبس
الاكل
وتحريك المقود مثل ما هو في سيارات تسلا
هذا هذا اقرب شيء موجود الان الى
بس للاسف العديد من جهود الشركات
المستثمره همم ذهبت هباءا مؤخرا تم
الاعلان عن افلاس ارجو اي اي اللي هي كانت
مسؤوله عن السيارات
ذاتيه القياده بالنسبه لبوكس واجن وفورد
هم اللي كانوا مستثمرين فيها بس حطوا فيها
الكثير من الاموال واغلقوها الشهر الماضي
لانه هي هو حقيقه ممكن تصير بس هي مكلفه
جدا وما هتكون مربحه لهم فممكن حطت فورد
مليار وحاطه همم عفوا نعم وفقت ولكن حتى
التوب 7 مليار دولار في اي اي جو وللاسف
سوف يتم اغلاقها لانه همم يقول همم
الرئيس همم التقنيه المتقدمه في فورد انه
صنع سياره كهربائيه او التقنيه التي تعمل
بها السياره عفوا ذاتيه القياده اصعب شيء
اصعب من وضع انسان على القمر
الوحيد ولا في اسباب ديت اخرى تعيق ان يتم
ت- تحقيق تقدم واحراز تقدم في هذه
التكنولوجيا مو بس مساله السياره الوحده
يعني مش بس انا سيارتي اشتريها اعطوني
مسود فاين لا في هناك سيارات عده في
الطريق ايضا الطريق مثلا هيئه مواصلات دبي
لها تجربه ناجحه ان شاء الله سيتم تطبيقها
ال همم السنه القادمه في جميره تحديدا
التاكسي بس همم تم تخطيط الشارع لذلك تمت
يعني هناك بنيه تحتيه تتقبل هذه السياره
الكهربائيه اللي ترافيك لايت السيارات
المحيطه اين تقف هذه السيارات يعني هي مش
بس انا احط السياره بالشارع ويلا لما نجحت
بيسان فرنسيسكو مثلا تنجح اكثر شيء بالليل
همم يعني نجحوا مؤخرا 416 في اوقست الماضي
بس كانت همم معظم هذه الركبات في الليل في
سان فرانسيسكو ما فيها هناك ازدحامات
وبعدين خسرت التقنيه كلفتتهم على ال 416
كلفتهم اكثر من مليار دولار خسائر فهي هي
مكلفه هي ممكنه بس مكلفه وغير مربحه للهمم
السيارات
ما هو حجم الاستمارات التي تم ضخها في هذه
التقنيه وهل تتوقع ضخ استثمارات اكثر
مستقبلات يعني الان ممكن اللي يتم ضخم
استثمارات مستقبليه لاستخدام التقنيه في
الروبوتات في مجال التوصيل هذا ما يتم
حاليا اليوم يتم استثمار في الصين فقط
اكثر من سته مليارات دولار فقط في مجال
اللي هي اللي توصل الروبوتات السيارات
الصغيره اللي توصل البضائع اللي لا تحمل
الركاب وما تخوف يعني لا سمح الله لو وصلت
شخص راح تكون الاذيه مثل سياره بس عندك
اكثر شيء مثلا بوش استثمرت بوش الالمانيه
استثمرت في شركه وير رايد صينيه اكثر من
اربع مليارات دولار شركه
اي اي انسان 600 شركه فورد مليار عندك وين
المعلن عنها فقط
المعلن عنه فقط غير اللي غير اكثر من خمسه
مليارات دولار فالاستثمارات ملياريه وما
زلنا حقيقه لم نحقق شيء متقدم بالموضوع
وما زالت هناك حوادث
عن ثقافه المستهلك هل تغير نمط الاستهلاك
هناك توجه اكثر لدى المستهلك للسيارات
ذاتيه القياده هل انت عندك استعداد تركبين
سياره
لانه كنت دايما انام وراء امي بالسياره
ورق انه افتح عيني واشوف امي مو موجوده
بالنسبه الي كان كابوس السياره ذاتيه
القياده يعني هل لا ادري حقيقه هل ممكن
الاشخاص يتقبلوني يمكن بعد انا احط كروز
الان لما اسوق على شارع الشيخ زايد شارع
عامه مفتوح بس هل عندي استعداد
شكرا شكرا